okay so now we get to the next and last
part of the program today my name is
Thomas plumb Henson from the University
of Amsterdam I'm a visiting scholar at
the southern Asian Institute this
academic year and I I enjoy myself
greatly it feels almost like being in
heaven and I don't know much about
heaven but I imagine it would be
something like it and it may be the and
the the nature of the so-called duties
that are given to me by Janaki and and
William for instance such as introducing
and Pandy as you will know that is not
you will imagine and you will hear very
soon it's not a very onerous task the
only onerous thing about it is the
length and complexity of the CV so Ian
ponder is is a very well-known scholar
well known to many of you I believe he
is at the moment from since 2006 he has
been the Arts and Sciences distinguished
professor at Emory University in Atlanta
before that he was at Johns Hopkins for
a number of years seven I think
and a number of years at Delhi
University as well teaching history in
all those places
Ian received his doctorate from
University of Oxford in 1975 and then
from his CV I could see there was a lot
of different short term appointments and
has gained was teaching in many
different places such as Leeds Hyderabad
he spent time in Calcutta in the early
80s and was at that point also part of
the founding collective became part of
the founding collective of the so Boston
Studies group or supporting studies and
edited a number of the volumes that came
out of that project he has also been a
visiting professor in a large number of
universities both in the u.s. Michigan
Chicago
many other places and also a number of
places in Europe Edinburgh Amsterdam
Heidelberg and so on some of the places
where we've actually met because I
happen to work there at the time when
Ian came and that's always been a great
fun and a great pleasure
ian has had a number of has done many
different things in his long career he
has started out with an interest which
is what really became or made his name
and made him into I think it's fair to
say the most important Indian historian
of communalism in a not just in North
India but in India as such and that
begins with a book in 1978 about the
ascendancy of the Congress which is and
then comes in 1990 the colonial
construction of communalism which
perhaps is still the most well known of
your many books and then an edited
volume that came out in 93 called Hindus
and others plus countless articles these
are all this is seminal an important
work and I think that the two essays I
want to mention that if you haven't read
them but you should immediately they
have appeared on hundreds of syllabi
across the world these smaller essays
but I think shows again at his very best
one of the most famous one is once it's
called in defence the fragment from 1991
and another one came in nineteen nine
canon muslim be an indian later on again
moves on to do a study of based on oral
history on partition and two books came
out of that memory history and questions
of violence ninety nine and remembering
partition from Cambridge University
Press in 2002 and then Guillen also
becomes one of the select few people who
has a omnibus from oh you P Delhi there
are not many of you but that came I
think
2014 five last year okay
now that would be enough for most people
to do all this but again began when he
was in Baltimore a serious interest in
in african-american communities in that
City way before the wire made it very
fashionable to think about Baltimore and
and began to pursue a comparison between
african-american identities and dallied
identities in India which is the direct
reason why he is will be speaking to us
today so there is a number of things
coming out of that his project is called
geneology geneology of prejudiced
african-american and Dalit middle
classes and some of you may have seen an
article that appeared in public culture
in the last issue I believe which is
called can there be a Dalit middle class
and I suppose that again will be
speaking to some of those issues today
there's also a book that it's just off
the printer which is called it's an
edited volume which is called supports
on citizens and their histories which is
which mixes articles on
african-americans and Dalits in a very
productive way
I've just had a chance to look through
it so I think with with all that we have
a lot to look forward to and I think we
should welcome again pander and give him
a hand
thank you very much Thomason thank you
to Janaki and the other organizers of
this wonderful occasion this very
special event for inviting me here and
giving me a chance to try out some of my
thoughts and present some ideas and some
work-in-progress
to you for feedback I have to say to
Thomas that the down side of heaven is
that Eastern yupi laborers get their
laborers from Eastern European now
masquerading as academics invited to
this particular conference and invited
to places where you yourself have
invited me but thank you all very much
for including me in this particular
conversation I also want to thank
Columbia's very long tradition of
scholarship and what it has given to me
and you will see much of it represented
in what I have to say today from
scholars who are here at the moment and
whose work I draw upon obviously like
Nick ducks and Gauri Viswanathan and my
old colleagues partha chatterjee and
should have the coverage and others but
also scholars who passed through who
were here for long length of time a
short short period of time starting with
dr. BR Ambedkar but coming down to much
younger scholars who've been here
recently for some length of time are
made mostly for example whose work again
I draw upon and Robin Kelly on the
African American side whose work - I
drove so the talk I'm going to give is
entitled the politics of difference and
it's a reflection on the Dalit struggle
it could be called sub alternate
indifference because of the track from
which I come but it is about difference
much more pointedly and I invoke in the
course of what I have to say today I
should invoke and the African American
experience and the woman's ex
woman's case and the black studies case
repeatedly and that in vacations are
important to the argument I want to make
I'm not able to detail very much today I
focus on the Dalit case for reasons of
this particular conference and for
reasons of time but I do want to say
that the other cases are important to
the argument I'm trying to make in this
recently published anthology subaltern
citizens and their histories
investigations from India and the USA my
colleagues and I have attempted to
reaffirm and radicalize the notion of
sub alternative by underlining its
inescapably political character that is
sub alternate II as always negotiated
contested marginality by stressing again
that it is not organized along a single
grid such as that of the economy is to
be leveraged and by insisting on the
relevance of the concept to advanced
liberal democracies and bourgeois
societies in our day no less than to the
so called developing and underdeveloped
countries of the third world all
pre-industrial and pre-modern times so
that's why the conversation between
scholars of the US and scholars of India
is of importance to us
Katrina and the way in which Bush gets
elected is of importance to us as much
as what happens in myopathies u P for
example okay what I want to do today is
to re-examine the idea of difference in
order to extend and deepen our
investigations of sub alternate e and to
return more sharply to the question that
feminists and other oppositional
movements have raised of how modern
societies and states can take account or
and live with difference in undertaking
this task it will help to prise away the
notion of difference from the rather
impoverished sense of diversity of
segments or minorities revolving around
Center usually the nation state a move
that assumes that the structure of
society the social organization and the
range of political possibilities is
always given from the start we already
know the structure we know it's Center
and it's a question of arranging pieces
and elements around it in some way
I want to trouble this assumption in two
ways the first which I hope will be
readily conceded is to recognize that
difference is by definition manifold and
fluid like sub opportunity only perhaps
more obviously so the idea of difference
cannot be taught or organized along a
single say cultural or biological grid
distributed along multiple axes it comes
in innumerable forms appearing
differently in different places
malleable evolving elements and
tendencies that come into view and
disappear change coalesce and reappear
in other forms and other networks in
other contexts thus the idea of
different signals fundamentally and
importantly a history and politics of
becoming of something that is always
coming into being not of the already
normalized stable and relatively
immutable secondly I will relate the
issue of difference or minority to which
it is commonly reduced that is the
pronouncement of radical alterity
allegedly based on natural biological
dissimilarity or long-established and
deeply rooted conditions of apartness as
in man versus women
man versus woman black versus white
african or oriental against european
hindu versus muslim christian as against
jew lesbians gays bisexuals transsexuals
against heterosexuals that pronouncement
of radical alterity i want to relate
that to the issue of civil alternative
that is articulations of dominance and
subordination and the hierarchical
ordering of social political and
economic power historians and other
social scientists seven recent years
generated significant research in debate
around the ideas of
of alternative and of difference in the
main however I suggest work around these
concepts has led to two different one
might even say autonomous narratives one
concerned ostensibly and primarily with
sub alternate II the other with
difference the most unexpected example
of this split and this is where I need
help from Robin Kelly and others but my
african-american is colleagues and
Americans colleagues are discussing this
with me to me this is a this is still a
hunch but it's something that I believe
is true in many ways the most unexpected
example of the split may be the
discourse on african-americans in the
USA where the history of one in the same
individual but a body the single
individual body and a social ascent
assemblage identified as black
repeatedly tends to get channelized into
two distinct streams the first dealing
with the african-american freedom
struggle which is framed in terms of
minority history assimilation or
separation D say emancipation
desegregation and the struggle for civil
rights and the second with material
deprivation poverty labor social
mobility and middle-class Ness now I'm
not suggesting that historians are not
written about these two things together
but class and race together in the
african-american context on the country
example Barbara fields and my colleagues
Earl Lewis and numerous others have
struggled to produce this history of
african-american existence and
experience as a history in which race
and class both work together in peculiar
ways the difficulty is that all too
often one of these say race gets reduced
to the other class or vice versa
and the history of the making of
subaltern g and of difference disappears
and Robin Kelly actually puts that point
well in making the point that history
from below has had little impact on the
study of african-americans there are
those who might argue he says that all
black history
is from below so to speak
since african-americans are primarily a
working-class population this view has
its problems however I'm still quoting
for many scholars concerned with
studying race relations fold the black
working class into a very limited and at
times monolithic definition of the black
community black working class equals
blackened or as nail paint another
colleague from Princeton puts it this
work has converted the black working
class into representative colored men
and by that means the historicizing
the question I want to ask is what
happens when we bring the discourses
surrounding sub alternate E and DIF
together how do these notions intersect
with enable or complicate one another
what happens to the idea of difference
or minority when it is not already
visible as a historically or
biologically or ideologically
established truth but has instead to be
constituted as a political category by
the subordinated the marginalized and
the disenfranchised
in the broadest sense of those terms
what in a word are the politics of
difference so my next section is called
the Jewish Question and you'll see why
and you'll also see I removed his recent
book on emancipation in the colony very
carefully
it will help to begin by setting the
received idea of difference in a more
precise historical context in order to
appreciate something of its force and
implications in recent political and
academic discourse a prominent theme in
the history of the world since the late
18th century has been the promise of
political emancipation the emancipation
of societies and groups that are marked
out as backward or disadvantaged or
simply adrift from the mainstream the
mainstream of human history in progress
as it is conceived by the Enlightenment
after the in line
it goes without saying that this
discourse of emancipation follows from
the attribution and assertion of a
certain privilege and centrality to
those able to accumulate power during
this period and more generally those
able to set what is called normality
right those therefore who were set down
the terms of history civilization
normality all poses the question of
emancipation indeed becomes at once a
question of emancipation assimilation
and of Tolerance a byword of the
Enlightenment the tolerance by the
majority the mainstream or more
accurately those able to lay down the
norms of acceptable levels of difference
because that's the critical issue
acceptable levels of difference there is
another important dimension to this
anticipated history of progress for much
of the 19th and 20th centuries the
question of political emancipation was
seen centrally as a question of national
emancipation in that conne state a
context once the principle of nation
states and national self-determination
had come to be accepted the question of
emancipation assimilation and tolerance
came to be focused on minorities
so-called throughout these centuries the
domain of the political was articulated
in terms of the relationship between a
state and its people a nation worked out
in significant measure through the
ongoing and mutual determinations of
nationality and minority the paradigm
case here is that of the Jews who emerge
as indeterminate uncertain minorities
neither insiders nor outsiders as
different countries in Europe come to
organize themselves into nation-states
in the 19th century the supposedly
enlightened tolerant civil society of
modern Europe and with it the idea of
the abstract citizens subject in the
rational universal order of the
nation-state is challenged by the very
existence and individuality of the Jew
who is seen as being too particular
istic and yet - global - rooted and yet
- dislocated at one in the same time the
problematic of difference takes the form
of the Jewish
question and Marx's essay on that
question becomes a lasting reminder of
the impossibility of the political
emancipation of the Jew as June that is
of political emancipation in a liberal
mode tolerating difference but demanding
uniformed many many scholars have
written under steam you will know much
of that literature and armies book is
only one of the most recent and I think
very insightful Restatement of much of
this thing and much of what I've said in
the last couple of paragraphs and draws
from his work I want to underline the
fact that the Jewish Question is a
metaphor for much more than the Jews to
put it to put it bluntly the Muslims are
the Jews of the later 20th century of
the later 20th century and beyond and
like the Jews the too narrowly
community-centered and they're -
worldwide there - deracinated and
they're - located at one in the same
time so they're they're not easily
unmarked invisible citizens of the
nation-state there's just too much going
on there their particular it is is a
problem basically the authority of what
I'm going to call this 19th century
problematic has remained largely
undiminished
even when nationalist discourse has lost
some of its earlier self-confidence and
visibility even when one might argue we
can think of States but no longer
nations academics and other political
commentators continue to present
arguments in terms of centers and
margins nations and the minorities they
must accommodate and national cultures
that are about religious or ethnic
coexistence and tolerance and have
little to do with labor and
relationships of the land and its
products let alone the impact upon us of
physical forces outside the social
cultural world changing conditions of
the environment and new possibilities of
reproduction cloning and perpetuating or
transforming the Houmas Homo sapiens as
a species being the nationalist
problematic of deviant cultural
minority remains fundamental and
state-sponsored programs to promote
multiculturalism tolerance and
assimilation proliferate as proof of
this the next section
I've called blacks Dalits and women
because I want to shift the discussion
of difference to another kind of other
within one that is signaled by my JAXA
position of the term sub ultimately
indifference I said to you this talk
could have been called subaltern t
indifference in that suggests position
I've also tried to make if the Muslims
are the recognizable Jews of the later
20th century the unrecognized other of
the era from the late 18th century
onwards have been slaves and
Untouchables women and other
subordinated groups whose existence and
particularity mount an equally important
challenge to the existing discourses of
civil society uniform civil rights and
the abstract citizens subject of the new
national and democratic order what
happens to our account of the politics
of emancipation assimilation
if the paradigmatic example of the
history of difference and minority is
taken to be not the Muslim or Jewish
Question
but the Dalit black or women's question
what - if the paradigm case of world
historical development is taken to be
not Europe which has clearly assumed
this place in the time of Hegel and Marx
if not earlier but North and South
America or South Asia in the 19th
century according to Marx England and
then perhaps Germany and then perhaps
Russia showed to the world the face of
the future in the 20th and 21st
centuries one might say it is the USA
and China and India Bolivia and Ecuador
better still one might recognize that
there is no one face to world history
but many masks dawned in various ways at
various times to produce the illusion of
one world with its natural ordering of
dominance and subordination male and
female
ethnicity versus ethnicity and so on the
specific character so if we take the
paradigm case as black the little women
rather than the Muslim Jew the specific
character of the Dalit of black and
stretching the point only a little also
the women's case is that it is seen as
being marked above all by conditions of
subordination and deprivation as the
first of the Jewish Muslim case which is
written primarily in terms of what would
be described as cultural deviance
the latter is viewed from the start the
Jewish Muslim case as a fully formed
alternative culture and dangerous other
whereas the precise status of women or
slaves or Untouchables as other or as a
minority is itself in doubt several
consequences follow therefore if we
substitute the paradigm of the valid
black woman for the Jew Muslim in our
investigation of political emancipation
and the making of modern societies and
States first our attention should be
immediately drawn to the making of
difference or of a minority or
minorities not already established in
their difference from the start
moreover if we take seriously the
position with the production of
difference and hence minority is a
process not a given demographic or
sociological condition we it becomes all
the more necessary to attend to the kind
of minority ization we encounter in the
history of particular states and
societies and to examine the
implications of distinct forms of
minority existence take for instance the
critical scholars attention and I'm
taking this from our mere - I'm quoting
those moments at which liberal culture
attempts sincerely the underlined
sincerely emphasizes it those moments at
which liberal culture attempts sincerely
as it were to resolve the question of
the Jews or in India of Muslims he is
interested mostly rights in how
liberalism historically has talked about
the modes of apartness of the Jews and
the history of their persecution in
Western society
and the kinds of solution it has offered
and he takes this very seriously it
works through them and talks about the
limits and the impossibility of
liberation in that liberal mode is the
same kind of statement even conceivable
for Dalits or blacks or women is the
Dalit black woman's question ever so
precisely formulated what would be the
modes of apartness views that race modes
of apartness of Dalits blacks women can
the Dalit black woman's question be
posed as a question of emancipation
assimilation by a dominant discourse
that already claims to accommodate or
include them to say nothing of the
question can women or for that matter
that Dalits or blacks lay claim to the
rights of separate nationhood which is
the extreme case for difference
instancing of different cultural
deviants or again consider the
proposition that nationalism necessarily
unsettles long large numbers of people
but rendering the minoritized
populations potentially moveable and
leading in many cases to the uprooting
of entire populations which we've seen
happen in in case after case in south
asia huge scale it is clear that the
minorities ation of Dalits blacks or
women does not automatically render the
movable on the contrary given the need
for their labor one might make the case
that minorities minorities ation is a
way of keeping them in their place in
both senses of that term on the other
hand the uprooting of the population or
uprooting of populations in the sense of
settled social structures may be
precisely what a subaltern minority
would call for in such an instance where
it's actually not possible taking blacks
of ballots of women as the paradigm case
of minority existence thus raises the
issue of insider-outsider status in a
rather different way from the case of
the Jews of the Muslims it necessitates
pointed questions about disguised forms
of internal colonialism and a more
careful investigation of layers
settlement privilege and power
instituted over time it may also tell us
rather more about the broader history of
mineralization including the Jewish
question of 19th century Europe that's
another story the very notion of
difference I'm suggesting suggests or
I've already said suggests variety
indeterminacy play in public life the
idea has for far too long now been
appropriated to notions of cultural
minority following from cultural
deviance in the context of claims to
national homogeneity our task as
investigators and critical commentators
must be to examine the complicated
history of this discourse obviously of
difference its deployment and its
effects the multiplicity and
ever-changing nature of what I described
as minorities and minority positions and
the numerous grids along which these
classifications operate grids that are
by no means easily reduced to the
organization and efficacy of the
nation-state idea the next section I've
called sub alternate indifference I
suggested in my introduction to this
book subaltern citizens in their
histories that the for grounding of
differences of gender sexuality caste
race etcetera at the hands of the state
and the dominant classes has long been a
way of organizing and naturalizing sub
alternative thus men are not different
it is women who are foreign colonizers
are not different as the colonized whose
land we're in who are different caste
Hindus are not different in India it is
muslims and tribals and Dalits who are
white anglo-saxon Protestant males are
not different in the United States at
one time or another everybody else is
white Australians are not different
Vietnamese boat people and Fijian
migrants to Australia and astonishingly
Australian Aboriginals
that earlier introduction difference
becomes a mark of the subordinated or
subaltern eyes measured as it is against
the purported mainstream the standard or
the normal what we are presented with
are two terms in binary opposition I'm
quoting Elizabeth Gracia two terms in
binary opposition hierarchically
structured so that the dominant term is
accorded both temporal and logical
priority it is in the attribution of
difference then that the logic of
dominance and subordination has commonly
found expression the pronouncement of
difference becomes a way of legitimating
and reinforcing existing relations of
power what the disadvantaged and the
marginalized and subordinated women
blacks Dalits sexual minorities
conquered indigenous peoples migrants
and unsettled populations have done in
response is to deploy the very category
of difference to demand a rearrangement
if not an overturning of prevailing
structures of power for 200 years and
more the political exertions of the
subaltern could be seen as a striving
for recognition as equals the history of
these efforts appeared as a history of
sameness and the right to sameness
one-man one-vote equal pay for equal
work the need to overturn inherited
structures of oppression and
discrimination to capture state power
and so on by the later 20th century
however the battle has been
self-consciously extended to encompass
another demand the demand for an
acknowledgment and even privileges of
certain kinds of difference the basis of
the new oppositional politics is not
only a growing awareness the differences
of gender of communal practices and ways
of being even of incommensurable
languages and beliefs have provided the
very ground for the diversity dances
density and richness of human experience
the new stance follows from a
recognition that difference and the very
deployment of ideas of difference has
been the ground for claims of identity
unitariness priority and privilege much
feminist work has refused to accept any
simple dichotomy between claims to
equality in claims to difference and
argued instead that he
quality requires the recognition and
inclusion of difference such
oppositional scholarship calls for a
fundamental critique of the ways in
which the idea of difference is deployed
and of the operations of categorical
difference a category that of course
marks out only some differences as being
consequential it is here in rethinking
the diverse locations and uses of the
proclamation of difference that the
example of the classically subaltern
communities Dalits
blacks conquered indigenous populations
women may have something unusual to tell
us given their uncertain and changing
statuses minorities and as insiders
outsiders who are essential to the
continuance of a given social and
economic order and yet have to be
confined to a subordinate or
marginalized place within it precisely
for the maintained maintenance of
established structures and Relations of
power the case I take up today is the
Dalit struggle and Baba Saheb Ambedkar
articulation of it in 20th century India
I suggest that the example of this
struggle enables us to reach beyond the
confines of enlightenment discourse and
facile propositions about deviance
assimilation and tolerance even though
the lit thinkers and activists of the
period remained constrained by the frame
of the anticipated nation state and the
language of majority and minority in the
forging of an alternative politics so
the next section which is a bit longer
and which I'm sure you've been wanting
me to come to as quickly as possible and
much of what I have to say here will be
familiar to a lot of people in this
audience it's just that I need to
rehearse some of this in order to make
the argument about the kind of
difference that I believe the Dalits
struggle actually allows us to see
allows us to foreground and think about
in the decades preceding the end of
British rule in India as is well known
Dalit spokespersons laid claim to being
and I'm quoting these little phrases a
statutory minority a separate element in
the national life a necessary party to
political constitution
negotiations regarding the country's
future a separate community even a
nation like the Muslims and the six they
were inevitably many different grounds
upon which the elite leaders advanced
the claim for the identifications of the
Scheduled Castes as they were called
after 1935 as a significant minority or
community among them the shared
experience or history of labor and
exploitation it's one kind of grand
propositions about shared sentiment and
suffering they commonly articulated and
at the other extreme the fact of
statutory recognition we are statutorily
a minority the particular difficulty
faced by Ambedkar and others in making
the claim that the Dalits were a
minority no different from Muslims Sikhs
Christians anglo-indians and other such
minorities was plain The Untouchables
outcasts depressed classes hydrogen
Scheduled Castes whatever the
appellation used for the assemblage
gained their distinctiveness at least
until they became a legally recognised
minority precisely from the fact of
their untouchability that is the
discrimination they had suffered at the
hands of Hindu society Gandhi was quick
to point out the paradox inherent in the
Dalit claim to existence as a separate
minority I'm quoting this is at the
roundtable conference in London 1931 we
do not want on our on our register and
on our senses Untouchables classified as
a separate class Gandhi says six may
remain as such in perpetuity so may
Muhammadans
so may Europeans will untouchables
remain Untouchables in perpetuity and
this is a very clever lawyer speaking
and but he picks the paradox which is of
importance in this respect the Dalits
were caught in an extraordinary bind
being defined by Hindu society and at
the same time part and not part of it
consider the ambivalence that appears in
Ambedkar presentation as lawman astir of
the case for the reform of the personal
law of the Hindus in the code bill at
one stage in the debate on the Hindu
code bill he referred to the Hindu
Shastras as your shaft sticks to a
Members interjection your Shastras
he responded by saying yes because I
belong to the other caste and a little
later I am an unusual member of the
Hindu community this is within the same
debate at another point in the same
debate he spoke of I'm quoting our
ancient ideals which are to my judgement
most archaic and impossible for anybody
to practice so there's this ambivalent
difficult position yesterday inhabitant
worked with in order to to convert her
opponent as much as anything else there
was clearly no easy escape from the
aggrandizing character of Hinduism even
for a leader who had declared 15 years
earlier I had the misfortune of being
born with the stigma of being in and
untouchable it is not my fault but I
will not die a Hindu for this is in my
power it is in this context that
Ambedkar opens up the question of the
meaning of so-called Hindu society or
community with a radical
reinterpretation of the of the Indian
past and therefore of the needs of the
Indian future Ambedkar's recasting of
Indian history as an extended and
unfinished struggle between brahminism
and Buddhism was a move of far-reaching
implication he was able to propose it I
submit precisely because he spoke for a
constituency very different from that
claimed by the leaders of other
pre-existing that is said to say on the
face of it already given and recognized
religious or racial minorities where is
the Congress's distribution of the
divide between the nation peoples
friends and enemies was into something
called India and its development on the
one side and anyone who would partition
the country or detract from its
development on the other and the
best-known minority version of the
recent history and current predicament
of the subcontinent was the muslim
league's proposal proposal of a
federation of communities threatened by
an arrogant and unduly privileged
majority Ambedkar went rather further in
his reexamination of how these putative
communities and their claims on the land
and the people came to be India is the
land which is in quoting India is the
land which is experience class
consciousness class struggle in its most
extreme form he wrote the land where
there's been fought a class war between
Brahmins and kshatriyas which lasted for
several
generations in which for which was
fought so hard and with such violence
that had turned out to be a war of
extermination and of course
another quote the history of India
before the Muslim invasions is the
history of a mortal conflict between
Brahmanism in Buddhism you know all of
this but it's it's a very important move
and which I'm going to say something
about he spells out the the proposition
about what this history has been about
and what different ideals have been
inequality was the official doctrine of
brahmanism Buddhism opposed it root and
branch and then he spells out the range
of issues that we've been talking about
this morning to a large extent and this
afternoon the shooter could never aspire
to be be a Brahman in the Vedic regime
but he could become a big shoe for a
Buddhist mendicant and occupy the same
status and dignity as did the Brahmin
similar change is noticeable in the case
of women under the Buddhist regime she
became a free person she could acquire
property she could acquire learning and
what was unique she could become a
member of the Buddhist order of nuns and
reached the same status and dignity as
as a Brahmin
how very galling this must have been to
the you know it talks about the forelock
which is really very bloody India's
untouchable communities were originally
Buddhist Ambedkar argued in his 1948
book called The Untouchables they were
thrust into the demeaning position of
untouchability when they clung to
Buddhism in the midst of a warrior and
court inspired resurgence of Brahminical
Hinduism broken men who declined with
Buddhism he says and I'm quoting we can
say with car with some confidence that
untouchability was born sometime about
400 AD it is borne out of the struggle
for supremacy between Buddhism and
Brahmanism which has so completely
molded the history of India and of the
courts that you know very very well from
from Bowers herbs writings I want to say
something about this claim on the past
and what it leads Ambedkar to what
arguments it opens up the claim owner
Buddhist past and the 1956 conversion to
Buddhism was not primarily a
I want to suggest at providing memory to
a memory this people to use Liana
garages evocative phrase although that
was certainly part of the point and part
of the reason for the presentation of
Indian history as the history of
struggle between Brahmanism and Buddhism
rather as Ambedkar's Restatement of
Buddhism showed very clearly this was a
conversion for the future in Ambedkar's
view as Christopher Quinn puts it
Buddhism is Christopher Quinn here okay
so I knew I was gonna quote people who
so as Krishna said Buddhism in
Ambedkar's view was the only viable
religion not only for the unheard
Untouchables of India but for the modern
world at large this regenerated Buddhism
was to provide a religion or an ethic
for our times and remember the Ambedkar
was ambivalent about his use of the term
religion or I think it was a little bit
uncertain how he should describe this
religion of our times a religion of
humanity or an ethic for Humanity of
liberty equality and fraternity but
especially of equality between men and
women upper caste and lower caste class
and class of reason and of progress with
compassion and understanding and a
minimum of violence all of that
investigators in the 1960s and the 1980s
many of them from from this country
found that the most common argument
given by the late converts in favor of
the Buddhist Dhamma was an argument
about universal human dignity the
opportunity to live like a man the
restoration of self-respect confidence
and an end to feelings of inferiority
all of which followed from the rejection
of Hinduism and its caste hierarchy with
conversion many of them said we became
human beings gotham's Dharma is like no
other as an anonymous Dalit woman song
has it a man finds Humanity there I
won't say just one recollection of a
conversion ceremony in a small remote
area in the Concord which appears in
formula bars
the iodine as an example of what
conversion appears to have meant to
people in places quite far and wide this
was a conversion that took place several
months after America's death in which
occurred of course as you know in
December 56 and power rights very
interestingly about those the the period
following the death of the Azov Ambedkar
and the discussions in the village
actually she says none of us understood
very well what exactly conversion meant
nor did we know much about this man
Ambedkar who had advised us to convert
yet the day of his passing came to be
and according indelibly printed in her
memory this is my appendix translation
it's a beautiful translation but I was
on 12 at the time that she returned from
school to discover family elders and
neighbors weeping one of them who worked
in another town decided to take the
overnight train to Mumbai to catch a
last glimpse of bhava sobs body the
atmosphere of mourning she recalls
lasted for several months while
information about Ambedkar's death his
struggles and his wishes trickled in
through the lives working in various
places outside the village some time
during this period preparations further
monther for conversion began the
conversion itself was a dramatic moment
something changed
baba recalls belief in evil spirits
position and incidents of actual
experiences of ghosts came to an abrupt
end after conversion and people like or
millas mother and she recalls this the
struggle of her mother it's the great
almost with anguish but but but in some
detail very interestingly people like
Camilla's mother who had strongly
believed in all of those things goes
somewhere appearance and evil spirits
and possession seem to take on a new
life the third man third ceremony took
place in the grounds of go got a college
in North Nagori the nearest large town
or Miller and her siblings went there
with the mother and other people of the
village
people poured in from everywhere she
writes in the midst of various
announcements the month of hoodlum
sharanam gachami floated down to us and
we joined our voices with with the
chanting crowd after the ceremony the
villagers were told to discard the gods
they worshiped and throw the idols into
the water
well Nicola says that she half expected
her mother would refuse given that
theirs was a priest's family and that
many of the images were actually rather
valuable they had they were expensive
instead of that her mother picked up
some idols and threw them into the water
herself the children also joined the
early morning procession that took the
idols to be thrown into the river a
Dalit elder placed a small statue of the
Buddha and a photograph of Ambedkar in
Ulm Ella's mother's prayer room people
went from house to house every evening
venerating the buddha recalls Pawar i'm
quoting their faces glowed you would
think there was no longer any need to
ask for happiness as it had
automatically come to us other
recollections of Dalit conversion to
Buddhism in different villages and towns
following Ambedkar's embracing of the
Dhamma in 1956 provide a similar sense
of anticipation and of a political
difference already at hand I think this
is important the political difference
the future is here in account after
account conversion appears as a magical
time the deeksha ceremony was completed
in a joyful atmosphere rites Shanta by
Krishna Krishna she calmly of the
ceremony in her husband's village of
cargo cargo knee in 1957 again the
struggle yielded us three jewels rights
baby calmly humanity education and the
religion of the Buddha the flame of him
started burning in our hearts we began
to walk and talk we became conscious
that we too are human beings a moment
suffused with ideas of liberation
rebirth and purity references to
spotless white recur in the lit accounts
of the immaculate
in the 1940s and 50s and this when I
first heard of it really quite striking
to me the number of people who talked
about how their parents insisted they
dress in spotless white we are told that
the cloth stores in Nagpur ran out of
white saris at the 1956 initiation of
Ambedkar in his half million followers
and that the women among the initiates
actually wore white men's Doty's the
spotless white is associated with the
promise of new fuller lives and the
purest and most inspiring of ideals
embodied in the Buddha and Bao receive
Ambedkar for all that and again in
Christopher Quinn others have written
about this muhammad khair of course as
we all know is represented in the garb
of a middle class intellectual much of
the time but nonetheless the pure white
is associated with these lives
how did millions of illiterate people
follow one man baby calmly asks about
Ambedkar though her question and her
answer could apply equally to the Buddha
and this is he was a man who believed in
himself he had courage and fortitude he
never changed his positions nor did he
ever compromise his principles for
selfish gain money prosperity fame
nothing could tempt him his heart was
soft and tender full of love for the
downtrodden his character was spotlessly
clean without any blemish this was the
moment of conversion and I'm suggesting
this is the construction of it I want to
conclude with a few thoughts about what
this tells us about the idea of
difference the longer long drawn-out
event of the Dalit conversion to
Buddhism and Ambedkar's reflections on
that event should help to clarify
something about the manner of this
establishment of political or for that
matter religious community and it is a
good point at which to return to the
question I began with of the making of
community and difference increasingly
from the 1930s Ambedkar and some other
Dalit leaders had began to advocate the
renouncing of Hinduism as
means of solving what was called the
problem of the untouchables Gandhi
dedicated in his own way to the
evolution of untouchability deferred
what was needed he argued was the reform
of Hinduism or what he called self
purification conversion was not the
answer
one cannot change one's religion as if
it were a house or a cloak he wrote for
Gandhi the threat threat of Dalit
conversion flowed from a political
rather than a religious impulse Ambedkar
joinder - this is important for my
purposes apart from making a pointed
comment on precisely the political
character of much of the religious
history of the world and of much that
counted as conversion he met Gandhi's
house and cloak metaphor with an equally
polemical but telling response religion
today was like a piece of ancestral
property he said
a piece of ancestral property passed on
from parent to child and accepted
unthinkingly what genuineness is there
in such religious belief quoting the
conversion of the untouchables if it did
take place he wrote and this in 1936
after a conference in Bombay the
conference which considered the question
of conversion possibly the conversion of
the untouchables we did take place would
take place after full deliberation of
the value of religion and the virtue of
different religions it would be the
first case in history of genuine
conversion the ballot leader here points
to the long process of thinking and
deliberation both social and individual
that must accompany the Dalits
conversion this is the future it is the
process that counts he might have added
in other words Ambedkar's first case of
genuine conversion might also be seen as
the first step in the making of a
difference which would also be a
political difference whatever else it
was a word here about the question of
culture and cultural difference in this
moment of conversion or resistance
scholarship on resistance literature as
it has been called has stressed the
importance of the rhetoric of refusal
that is found in much oppositional
writing a refusal a this is Rigoberta
mench Toni Morrison and all sorts of
resistant literature which is taken on
this through this kind of interesting
investigation of the rhetoric of refusal
a refusal that marks the readers
anomalous position and signals the
distance of the reader from the
narrative it's a distance that we not
going to be able to bridge and we do not
want to bridge for a whole variety of
reasons I am suggesting that this is a
distance difference that is also to be
found in that it self assertion but not
I submit as the difference of pure
culture in the case of the Dalits as in
that of many others have organized
minorities the internally colonized we
might call them who do not inhabit a
geopolitical space that provides easy
ground for a politics of separation or
of independent nation
Newt and I would include blacks and
women here they said earlier it has
never been a straightforward task to
mark out a sequestered domain of an
autonomous culture the claim of a
unified and alternative culture and
tradition is established here if it is
established only through long and hard
struggle and recall again the women's
movement which has lived with this for
ever so long and for forever in a sense
for and against an argument about a
culture of women womankind you can't
resolve that one in some sense as one
should not resolve that would be it
would be the politics of that position I
think it is this alternative culture and
tradition if it is established I'm
suggesting after long and hard struggle
it is more deliberately forged and far
more openly contested than the cultural
flames of more privileged groups with
more secure cultural institutions and
funding and greater access to political
power and the politics that accompany
the construction of this alternative
culture and tradition I never quite so
easily wished away the resistance
refusal found in the ballot movement and
valid history then is not that of an
already available culture or identity
the cultural identity of Dalits or X
Untouchables or however we might
describe the group the facet of
resistance the foreign accent or
unassimilable distance that the
resistance literature people are talking
about is not the resistance of another
culture it is instead the resistance of
a different politics and the call for a
differently imagined future this is not
a politics that flows from cultural
difference somehow already constituted
but rather a culture that flows from
political difference and an alternative
political perspective and I think it's
important to insist upon this and
underline it in a many-sided engagement
with the history of sub alternative and
difference in the subcontinent
what dr. Ambedkar analyzed seems to me
analyzes
in many many different ways many
different times there's a question of
labour and exploitation in production
the oppressions of caste quite outside
quite aside from the matter of economic
production and distribution the
subordination and confinement of women
the challenges and containment of
different religious as well as political
ideals and practices his work underlies
underlines the process of the creation
of these confinements and oppressions
these identifications and these ideals
this is the history and the politics
offer becoming and of political cultural
communities yet to be not as it appears
in Gandhi's exchanges with Ambedkar at
this point have already established
stable and relatively immutable
identities and commitments so I want to
conclude simply by returning to become
Lee's comment this I quoted to you the
struggle yielded us three jewels
humanity education and the religion of
the Buddha the flame of him started
burning in our hearts we began to walk
and talk we became conscious that we are
human beings yielded us three jewels
yielded is an important word and it
applies to the US in this statement the
Dalits as well as to humanity education
and religion we began to walk and talk
we became conscious the struggle yielded
up the Dalit community a Dalit politics
and the outlines of a Dalit future as
other struggles and other elements and
other arrangements of power will yield
up other communities fresh alliances and
possibilities and perhaps still
undreamed-of futures
can we have some questions 15 minutes
shirakami
just in the course of your presentation
you mentioned that how clever of Gandhi
it's trivial though regarding the
minority status for Dalits the Sikhs and
Muslims will remain as six and Muslims
there are Santa so loose will not remain
as Untouchables and when you set clever
I thought it's very loaded and maybe you
wanted to imply that as long as there is
in dignified seclusion that is the
Dalits and dignified seclusion that the
Brahmins when they coexist and I think
untouchability in spirit then thing will
continue that which Gandhi did not
realize that's what you wanted to imply
go into the question yeah because see on
the one hand you have dignified
seclusion that the Brahmins they didn't
want others to touch them because it
will be there will be you know polluted
on the other side they didn't want
others to interact with the Dalits
because they are impure so the pure and
impure as long as they remain in
opposite ends Vantage ability in spirit
and you know practice will continue
that's what I thought you wanted to
imply and that's what this statement
clever you know was attributed to Gandhi
I thought
um would you like to respond to do you
want me to take a few more questions
I liked them and I would send by I would
agree with exactly what you're saying
but I think Gandhi was making a much
more what should we say mundane point
that there is a group that is called
Untouchables there is a practice called
untouchability he's much more what
should we say literal about the
existence of these things I don't think
he's thinking particularly of a future
and of other ways subtle ways in which
this my persistent spirit world would
survive he is he is simply that's why I
said it was a clever argument he is
simply saying that this category and
these practices they should not stay
forever right surely you don't want that
that that's the argument that you make
I think you help me clarify something
I've been wondering about a long time my
name is Gary tartakov how much of our
discussion and it's big discussion my
whole lifetime of difference how much a
discussion of difference in this context
of blacks and elites is an avoidance of
the discussion of exploitation but it's
easier to talk about color than it is
exploitation or it's easier to talk
about pollution than it is the
exploitation of those who are then
called polluted well I think the your
question answers it and basically one
requires that kind of investigation
continuously my concern is that the one
masquerades as the other repeatedly and
that's that's the escape from the task
of the the critic and investigator which
must be to find how each one comes into
place each one of those how they come
into place because both exist very much
so but if you can talk about
exploitation in one seminar and about
color and another seminar you're safe
you're fine you can talk about both of
them many many people do and say it's
exactly the same thing right
it's exactly the same thing and you've
evaded the task once again they're
really different discrimination is mean
and unpleasant and sometimes against the
law but exploitation violates what we
say is the Equality which they all have
exploitation is an absolute denial of
democracy and it's mean and exploitative
and sometimes against the law
hi my question I don't know how much is
it directly relevant to what you
presented but I still would be great if
you can just say I'm struggling with
that question so if you can help me with
that so the linkages I pavani the
linkages I think which I can make from
your presentation and the first session
which we had is and you make a line that
the little leader claims are based on
like share or shared experience of his
exploitation their labor and all all
these things so I just want to know how
does the recent historical and
historical anthropological research
which argues that caste is either
colonial construction or colognian
Rashidah fication effects the memory of
the memoryless people specially visibly
just quickly others visa vie reservation
debate because reservation does
affirmative action doesn't just remain
it transforms from a right to a charity
because the history of the people have
been history of oppression operation as
a difference has been cut short by
arguing that colonial it let's blame the
British for that so I just say if I'm
struggling with this question cuz I ha I
hear this in the discourse both in JNU
in IIT and when I do a field work in the
villages in Rajasthan so it has like the
capillary reaction has taken that the
less not the Brahmins the British
becomes of our means just very quickly
that I don't think anyone is saying the
British manufactured caste it didn't
exist you know there was no such thing
colonial construction means some very
interesting things about the way in
which caste gets moldy and I don't think
I've not heard where many people say
that reservations or affirmative action
is a bad thing in itself I mean I think
there's there's a lot of question about
how how one might most effectively work
with that instrument that's available
with with things that have already been
given to us but all of the questions
you're asking are going to remain in
place there's there's no short answer to
them from me or from you as a suspect
myself or ammonia with all this modern
education philosophy do you ever think
that even in another 50 years
the Hindus will learn to respect the
other Hindus as equal see on I'm going
to take a couple more questions for you
and gather a few questions and then you
cannot yeah thanks for giving um this
sake Mohan you just in the beginning in
the first part of your lecture you know
it's really interesting to me but I have
the second part is really fantastic the
first part you know you mentioned about
Sebastian assertions importance like
that do you try to you know you know put
you know Dallas in the lineup of with
general women or anything likely because
religious cuca include al it's only in
the ninth volume until then Dennis
they're not important you know say the
question you know I don't know this is
the whole lecture you know you have
given it it's really getting a director
because III think that I I learned that
you try to put the dollars in the vault
and position because Sebastian questions
middle position some that are in the
last question
or out of the cast thank you
my name is Chania this is again I really
like the way in which you try to draw
this larger perspective in terms of both
historically and also in terms of
connecting caste and race and to pick up
the thread from what Fatah monomethyl
left in the morning about this lack of
ethical engagement in the earth politics
especially in contemporary India where
basically the either OBC politics of the
lip palate is one of the important
problem is this not having ethical
engagement and he also mentioned another
interesting thing is that the actual
ethical engagement in Indian history
happened from 1920s to 1950s which means
especially when Gandhi and Ambedkar are
together and trying to resolve this
whole issue of untouchability so to add
to what actually so to pick up two
things one thing about Gandhi Ambedkar
and also you also talked about Dr
Nagaraj it's very interesting in the
sense don't you think that there is very
problem both Gandhi embed Gandhi and
Ambedkar realized that there are
problems with liberal democracy which
cannot resolve this whole question of
caste in which both for Gandhi it's a
torturous process of selling self
cleansing which becomes a means to end
the untouchability for Ambedkar what
happens to end of his life one of the
things about coming into religion as an
important part of a man special project
I think don't you think this issue of
race and caste needs to be seen beyond
Rea liberal democracy where basically
religion becomes a very important aspect
even Malcolm X in the NDC's Islam is
important the way of can do you want to
answer those and we'll take a few more
and then invite people to the reception
I'm not sure Romania really wants an
answer to the question will Hindus
change in the next 50 years let's hope
so
say right to our cam Mohan's question
you know I I don't know about subalterns
being a mid position and the critique of
subaltern studies and in its earlier
incarnations is well-taken there's no
problem there were no women there there
were all sorts of things that were
really wrong with the Walton studies and
all sorts of things that might remain
wrong I am not I'm not I'm not doing
subaltern studies here I was
investigating the question of difference
and in the question of difference I I
put it to you I put it in this in this
particular argument that it's the
culturally deviant that becomes the
paradigmatic case and I'm simply putting
forward an argument about how groups
that do come to be seen as minorities as
marginalized as people that do need
state intervention protection of permit
of action all sorts of things okay
if these alternative groups like the
little acts of women and these are very
very different groups will get very
different histories of you pursued each
one through but if one took those sorts
of examples as the paradigmatic case of
difference what results do we come up
with and I think we come up with very
different results that's the basic
proposition I mean you want to include
Dalits amongst of all time so you don't
you want to use the term subaltern or
not that's that's entirely in the hands
of the scholar and the political
commentator this there's no reason to
use that term specially so just a
shorthand which works for certain kinds
of relationships that's and Shanaya the
I think you the question the short
question is beyond the Liberal
Democratic possibilities and
and alternatives propositions isn't
there need for looking at something like
religion and the answer is well clearly
the Liberal Democratic schemes are
insufficient they inadequate for all
sorts of reasons and we can see that
that's why the Jew cannot be liberated
as Jew the Muslim cannot be regulated as
Muslim cannot remain mostly men be
liberated
can women remain women and be liberated
you know there's going to be something
very interesting in articulate in
working through this question so
religion or moves out of mainstream
claims to national culture absolutely
vital to the to the stars
but I want to ask the question too and I
ask it and out of dr. Baker's work here
how do we read this religion how do we
read this alternative culture and the
proposition I am making is that this is
a culture of an alternative politics and
that is what we must foreground to a
large extent I don't see that as a
couple more questions John thank again
romney-ryan Rohit from University of
Pennsylvania again it was a great talk
and I am also thinking along these some
of these issues I'm interested you said
to radicalize the character of subaltern
a TA or subaltern and I'm wondering what
is it in the contemporary world that
makes this kind of discussion possible
that we think of sub Alton you not
talking about black Dalit and women I
mean what is it that made this possible
is it our arrival in the u.s. I mean
crudely put and what was it that did
make it possible in India this kind of
discussions or to put it in another way
was it the collapse of Marxism in many
ways that made this discussion possible
collapse of maths in an intellectual way
and the way in which support the studies
has moved beyond this you know so the
sense
to the extent that it does I'll split
that into two into two parts ROM I mean
this these conversations are taking
place in India you don't have to come to
the United States to begin these
conversations there's no question of
that so I do not think that you know
your move to Pennsylvania's is the is
the reason that you would begin to think
about this question the collapse of
Marxism has a lot to do with rethinking
the Revolutionary subject of the future
there's no doubt about it
and subaltern said it was partly
response to that the relationships
between very different craft the
question of difference was not central
to classical Marxism it says it's as
simple as that
feminism brings it forward makes it an
absolute central question of modern
politics and we all everyone in the
later twentieth century has to negotiate
the question of difference along with
the question of dominance and
subordination singing classically mark
systems
well it's 6:45 it's 5:45 and I have wine
I hope that is good I have wine
I have hors d'oeuvres Seltzer orange
juice sparkling cider so please join me
in thanking John Pandey for a wonderful
plenary address join us
you